Diener des Volkes so lautete der Titel
der Fernsehserie mit der wololineski
berühmt wurde der Mann der jetzt als
Präsident seinem Land der Ukraine
unermüdlich dient sein Volk und der
Westen sollen ihm größten Respekt in
Deutschland wird er dafür nächste Woche
mit dem Karlspreis geehrt und heute war
er überraschend zu Besuch in Den Haag wo
er Putin vor dem Internationalen
Strafgerichtshof sehen will er kam wie
immer im kampfgrünes Sweatshirt vom
Schauspieler zum Präsidenten wer ist
Vladimir selensky unser Thema in der
phoenix-runde
Phoenix Runde
natürlich wollen wir alle hier einen
anderen Vladimir hier vor dem
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof in Den
Haag sehen den Vladimir nämlich der ist
verdient für diese kriminellen Taten zur
Verantwortung gezogen zu werden hier in
der Hauptstadt des internationalen
rechtss
und wir sind sicher dass das auch
geschehen wird wenn wir den Krieg
gewonnen haben werden und wir werden
diesen Krieg gewinnen
ein selbstbewusster ukrainischer
Präsident heute in Den Haag herzlich
willkommen aus Berlin ich darf Ihnen
meine Gäste vorstellen series um lenny
ist bei uns Politikwissenschaftler
Gründer des European resiliens
Initiative centers in Berlin und der hat
auch einmal das Büro der böllstiftung in
Kiew geleitet begrüße Sonja zegree
kulturkorrespondentin der Süddeutschen
Zeitung studiert das logistin lieber
Korrespondentin erst in Moskau und dann
in Kairo herzlich willkommen Michael
Thumann er leitet als außenpolitischer
Korrespondent derzeit zum dritten Mal
schon das Büro in Moskau und sein
neuestes Buch Revanche Putin das
bedrohlichste Regime der Welt geschaffen
hat beleuchtet Moskau und auch Russland
natürlich ich begrüße Professor Martin
Schulze er lehrt Geschichte der Ost- und
Südosteuropas an der LMU München
Mitglied der deutsch-ukrainischen
historischen Kommission und sein
neuestes Buch heißt der Fluch des
Imperiums und darin beschreibt er die
Geschichte Russlands und der Ukraine von
1700 bis heute also viele Menschen die
sich sehr gut auskennen mit unserem
Thema und der Ukraine und Russland ja so
ein Lenny wir haben es eben gesehen
selensky heute überraschend in Den Haag
vor dem Internationalen Strafgerichtshof
mit dieser Forderung Putin muss hier hin
ist das Symbol oder ist es mehr ja so
wie der Krieg jetzt läuft hoffen wir
natürlich alle darauf dass das Tiere die
baldige Realität sein wird ich kann mich
daran gut erinnern als ich im Jahr 2015
nach Kiel kam damals für die
burgstiftung dann war ich in der
Redaktion des Fernsehen formatke und da
standen da gab es eine Ausstellung von
Plakaten im Korrektur und eine von
Plakaten war sehr schlecht gebildet mit
dem einzigen Satz der Haag kann warten
und damit sagten ja also das ist
natürlich sehr scharf formuliert und
jetzt spitzig aber das ist nicht die
Realität und in der Tat der Herr kann
warten und so wie es wir sehen wen
Russland und wenn nicht ist sondern when
wenn Russland diesen Krieg verliert dann
wird es bestimmt schon Russland sein und
egal wer der nächste Präsident in
Russland sein wird der einfachste Weg
für ihn oder für sie Russland im Westen
dann besser zu vermarkten wäre die
hauptkriegsverbreche auszuliefern und
das wäre natürlich auch die Leute mit
Putin der beste Kandidat weil er
offensichtlich für alle diese geholtaten
persönlich steht er hat klar gesagt sie
lenzke wir werden diesen Krieg gewinnen
Herr Thomann ist das ähm
eine Art wo er sich selber Mut zu
spricht oder ist das eine Realität
Realität ist es noch nicht aber ich
denke er muss das sagen er sollte das
auch sagen weil er schließlich seit
Anfang des Krieges und das hat ja auch
sein Mythos ein bisschen mitbegründet
dass er eben einfach da geblieben ist
und dass er gesagt hat wir gewinnen das
und wir lassen uns nicht unterkriegen
wir verlieren Kiew nicht und die
Schlacht um hier hat er ja gewonnen und
er hat auch große Erfolge gehabt im
vergangenen Herbst und nun setzen die
Ukrainer eben mit der Frühjahrsoffensive
die herkommen sollen noch einmal an zu
einem neuen Versuch also insoweit denke
ich spiegelt das einfach die Ukraine
zwischen den ukrainischen Willen diesen
Krieg nicht zu verlieren sondern
tatsächlich zu gewinnen was am Ende dann
gewinnen heißt da das wird man dann
sehen wie sich das aus Buchstaben wird
aber dieses Ziel ist fest vor Augen und
es gibt den Kraft ja wie sehen sie ist
dass er da heute hin gereist ist was
bedeutet das für die Ukraine
es ist Symbol und Realität es ist ein
sehr reales Symbol das in Den Haag ist
und Den Haag entfaltet seine Wirksamkeit
schon jetzt also man muss damit rechnen
dass und Putin muss damit rechnen dass
er am Ende da stehen wird niemand hat
damit gerechnet dass Milosevic da einmal
stehen würde aber es ist so gekommen und
was die
kriegsaussichten angeht viel entscheidet
sich über den kriegsgeist und da ist wie
Michael Thumann auch schon sagte
selenski eben eine Verkörperung des
kriegsgeistes er tritt ja nicht in einer
förmlichen Uniform auf sondern in einem
olivfarbenen T-Shirt also einer
Verkörperung von Volkskrieg viel eher
als von Militär
würden sie das sehen dass er hat ja er
kann ja nicht vorher groß ankündigen
dass er da hinkommen er war jetzt
überraschend in Den Haag es gab jetzt
Nachrichten darüber dass er auch nach
Berlin kommen soll also wie wichtig sind
diese Besuche und die Tatsache dass er
die Ukraine verlässt dann es ist sehr
wichtig es ist vor allen Dingen wichtig
in einer Zeit wo man natürlich liest und
hört das ist schon auch auf westlicher
Seite immer größere
Überlegungen gibt und auch Gespräche
gibt dann doch irgendwann mal intensiver
hin Verhandlungen einzutreten also diese
diese ganz ungebrochene Ukraine Euphorie
die es im letzten Jahr gegeben hat die
ist ja im zweiten Jahr des Krieges nicht
mehr so da also man sieht was das kostet
man sieht was ist die Steuerzahler
kostet man sieht man sieht nicht wie es
endet man sieht auch nicht wann es endet
das kommt alles dazu und insofern ist
das natürlich sozusagen sein Auftritt an
diesem Ort sozusagen die Anrufung von
Nürnberg das ist hoch symbolisch das ist
das was er kann und das was ihnen im
Westen ein Michael Schumann hat das Wort
Mythos gebraucht da wäre ich sehr
vorsichtig aber was ihm zumindest eine
unglaubliche ein unglaubliches Prestige
eingebracht hat muss erwerben Herr
sondern sehen Sie es auch so dass sie
Zustimmung ja abnimmt über die
Unterstützung naja man kann nicht sagen
dass sie Zustimmung abnimmt aber
natürlich muss man werben also wir sehen
dass diese Krieg in welchem kriegen die
Ukraine drinnen Blut soll zahlen
deutlich länger dauert als diese Krieg
dauern sollte wenn überhaupt hätte der
Westen noch vor dem russischen großen
Einmarsch die richtigen Waffen geliefert
nicht nur die jeweils und endlos war als
die mutigen Brite und Amerikaner
geliefert hätten und auch die Polen
Lieferungen so eine Luftabwehrraketen
ähm flugapparaketen
dann hätte diese Krieg wahrscheinlich
nicht ausgebrochen wäre weil es Putin
dann glaubt okay gut das vielleicht
mache ich jetzt nicht dieses Jahr im
Sommer im ersten Sommer als die
Ukrainerinnen nach den waffenbaden dann
kamen die Waffen zu spät damit die in
der Sonne Offensive der Ukraine benutzt
werden können jetzt stehen wir im
zweiten Jahr des Krieges und warten auf
die vorstandsoffensive ja warten darauf
die Jets sind noch nicht da die Panzer
sind Gott sei Dank da und die AFD sind
da aber die Langstrecke Raketen sind z.B
nicht da das heißt dass die ukrainische
Offensive wenn sie Staaten startet
sowieso dass sie war wahrscheinlich
nicht so erfolgreich sein wird wie sie
sein könnte und das heißt man muss
ständig den Westen darauf
hinweisen dass die
der versucht die Eskalation an
angebliche vermutliche mythologische
Eskalation zu vermeiden am Ende den
Krieg verlängert und das macht sie
Lenski jede Zeit wenn er kommt da gibt
uns was wir beenden diesen Krieg er ist
ja wirklich unermüdlich kommen wir
gleich noch mal drauf jetzt gibt es aber
aktuell noch die Diskussionen oder es
gab zwei Drohnen über dem Kreml und
jetzt sagt der ehemalige russische
Präsident mit wdev als Reaktion
sozusagen erfordert die physische
Eliminierung des ukrainischen
Präsidenten selenski hat wie muss ich
das verstehen und wie ordnen Sie die
dieses Geschehen mit diesen mit den
Drohnen ein
mit der ja früher selbst mal Präsident
war als er mit Putin tauschte die Plätze
und heute eigentlich auf einem relativ
marginalen Posten ist Stellvertreter des
Sicherheitsrats ähm Chefs versucht sich
immer durch besonders radikale
Äußerungen in die in die Mitte wieder zu
bringen und ins Gespräch gelingt ihm
auch dadurch weil er in unserer Sendung
schon wieder auftaucht ich halte das was
er am Ende sagt nicht für so
entscheidend
und trotzdem
denke ich das was die Drohnen und wir
wissen ja nicht wer dahinter steckt war
es tatsächlich eine pro-ukrainische
Gruppe zuletzt hieß es jetzt aus dem
Moskauer Gebiet womöglich gestartet oder
sind es vielleicht auch pro russische
Gruppen oder ist es in irgendeiner Form
sind es die Sicherheitsapparate selbst
die das in irgendeiner formuliert haben
alles mögliche sein ich ich mich auf
keine Variante fest aber
Tatsache ist das jetzt im Moskau eine
gewaltige Inszenierung der Empörung und
das Wunsches nach Vergeltung entsteht
und das ist halt besonders wichtig vor
dem 9 mai dem Tag des Sieges den man ja
am nächsten Dienstag feiern möchte und
wo man dann halt eben auch zeigen möchte
dass man weiterhin trotz verschiedener
Rückschläge in der letzten Zeit in der
Tatsache dass man über die Stadt bachmut
in der Ostukraine schon ein halbes Jahr
kämpft und kaum ein Meter vorankommt
dass man halt eben gewillt ist jetzt
noch mal eine Schippe draufzulegen und
da könnten wir ich kann nicht
voraussagen was aber wir könnten in
irgendeiner Form noch mal russische
Aktionen sehen in den nächsten Tagen die
dann mit den Drohnen begründet werden
sie hat gesagt auf die Vorwürfe des
attentatsversuches das geht ja die Frage
ob man sein Attentat versucht war auf
Putin hat er gesagt wir greifen Putin
oder Moska nicht an wir kämpfen auf
unserem eigenen Territorium und
verteidigen unsere Dörfer und Städte er
hat ja vor Journalisten in Helsinki
gesagt der war ja vorher nach Holland
gefahren ist hat sich irgendwie
glaubwürdig ist das naja sie haben ja
schon also natürlich greifen sie auch
ein wenig außerhalb der Ukraine an und
der Westen versucht das dann immer also
auch die Amerikaner versuchen das dann
immer so ein wenig einzuheben solange
das ein gewisses Maß nicht überschreitet
ich wäre da auch bei Michael Thumann man
weiß es einfach nicht was da passiert
ist aber das ist natürlich ähm
sozusagen das jetzt gewisse Waffen nicht
geliefert wurden weil man eben nicht
ganz sicher war ob da nicht doch
irgendwas mal tiefer im russischen
Hinterland runtergeht und was das dann
für Reaktion auf russischer Seite
auslösen würde das beobachtet man ja
jetzt schon viele Monate aber trotzdem
wenn man sagt man weiß nicht wie man es
einzuordnen hat aber wie gefährdet ist
sie denn wäre das die ultimative
Vergeltung von Russland wenn es wirklich
ein Attentat auf silence gegeben
in der Situation ist er vom ersten
Kriegstag angewiesen ist die
Verkörperung der Ukraine erst das Ziel
der russischen Propaganda und sicher
auch russische attentatsanstrengungen
wenn sie gelingen
ich meine wir haben darüber gesprochen
was hat sich geändert seit dem Beginn
des Krieges und sicherlich wird deutlich
aus ukrainischer Sicht was das an an
Menschenleben kostet aus westlicher
Sicht wie Frau sie Kriege gesagt hat
vielleicht auch die finanziellen Kosten
aber es bleiben doch zwei Grund hat
Sachen bleiben doch vom ersten kriegste
Tag angestehen einmal dass es um die
Existenz der Ukraine geht und dann die
simple Einsicht das in der Ukraine die
westliche sicherheitsordnung verteidigt
wird und deswegen hat sich im Grunde
auch so wenig verändert seit Beginn des
Krieges manchmal haben ja den Eindruck
es ist so ein praktisch wie so ein
Showdown Putin gegen silence geht das
ist jetzt das worauf man noch fast mehr
schaut als auf all die anderen Opfer ist
das ein richtiger Beobachtung natürlich
auf keinen Fall sagen weil er selensky
für überhaupt nicht sagt das
fraktionsfähig hält sondern Putin hat es
mit dem gesamten Westen aufgenommen
Putin kämpft gegen die NATO der Westen
hat sich verschworen Russland in die
Knie zu zwingen und Russland kämpft um
sein Überleben das ist die Lesart also
kleiner hatte es nicht und nur einen
Satz noch zu mit Videos und auch ob sie
ins
gefährdet ist also das ist völlig
redundant was mit Videos da gesagt hat
natürlich versuchen die Russen selinski
umzubringen das haben sie von Anfang an
gemacht und da ist auch so gar nichts
Neues dran und wie gefährlich und das
nochmal ganz konkret Mann auf die Frage
ob er nach Berlin kommen kann was jetzt
schon durchgesickert ist als Nachricht
gestern wie wahrscheinlich ist es dass
er dann überhaupt noch kommt ja das ist
natürlich die kaffeesatzleseerei die
wissen es nicht also vielleicht kommt er
nicht nach Berlin sondern nach eine
andere Ortschaft vielleicht wird es
nicht in Deutschland getan wir wissen es
nicht wir werden es bald sehen und ich
glaube das ist am Ende nicht so
entscheidend ob er den
Friedenspreis dann in Deutschland
persönlich bekommen oder über eine
Videobotschaft und es ist auch am Ende
nicht entscheidend ob selenski
irgendwelchen Preis überhaupt bekommt
anscheinend ist ob du Ukraine die Waffen
bekommen und viele Städten und Berlin
war eben noch nicht und die die Preise
also ich würde mir sehr wünschen wenn
diese emotionale und symbolische
Unterstützung der Ukraine in Form von
Fahnen über die Gebäuden von Flyern vom
Gesang von von anderen Sachen dann
irgendwie praktische und äh in die in
die Tatsachen und Waffen ähm Reform
geliefert wäre was zu diesem diese Frage
ob Putin sein Problem mit zuletzt hat
ich stimme diese Putin natürlich will
den Westen bezwingen kein Zweifel daran
aber selensky ist für ihn auch wichtig
da ist lensky ist für ihn schlimmer als
Feind
selensky ist zuerst ist lensky für Putin
ein Problem weil sie lensky einen
ethnische Jude ist
und Russland ist ein Erz antisemitisches
Land und baut seit schon seit so wie
Union Zeit ganz gerne die fein Bilder
vom Juden also schon von den
nahospolitik der Sowjetunion und so
weiter wenn wir heute die Karikaturen
die antisemanski Karikaturen in
russischen Medien uns anschauen und vor
allem nicht von der ersten Liga sondern
die kleinen Medien oder internet-turen
da wir uns mit einem riesigen Nase
gemalt mit einer Kipper mit Haarlocken
und so weiter bis ein Feindbild eines
judens dann zweitens zweitens das
wichtigste ist dabei weil ich sehe Frau
sehr stark den Kopf sehr schnell also
das ist das
überzeugt mich tatsächlich nicht das
Putin gegen silensky etwas hat weil er
Jude ist man kann Putin vieles vorwerfen
aber diese Art dass er ich kann mich
auch an keine einzige Äußerung von Putin
erinnern dass sie das mal zum Thema
gemacht hat also das kann ich mich
überhaupt nicht daran erinnern dass es
irgendwie eine Rolle gespielt hat dass
wir das silence gejudo war man kann
darüber reden man kann darüber reden ob
dieses ganze Konstrukt von wir machen
eine denazifizierung in einem Land wo
der Präsident Jude ist ob das schon
antisemitisch ist darüber kann man reden
aber nicht dass er also
die Karikaturen
das gesagt hat
also es geht vielleicht weniger um die
Person von Putin sondern um die Frage
wie weit gibt es Antisemitismus in
Russland und die Beobachtung die sie
machen sind richtig aber wahrscheinlich
sind wir uns einig das Russland jetzt
keinen Erz antisemitisches Land ist
die Person welche das einschätzen kann
ich legte die lange Zeit in Russland
auch in die Schule in Russland kann das
ein bisschen einschätzen so die Frage
vor den Karikaturen wir hatten auch in
der Situation die sehr interessanten
Kreaturen über den selenski Welt jetzt
zu Recht als
nahezu antisemitisch angestupt worden
waren da wäre es dieses Thema jetzt
nicht erwartet aber wichtig für Putin
ist da selensky war ein
russischsprachige Komiker eine russische
sprachige wo macht es denn seine
Karriere in Moskau der machte sein
Vermögen und er ist ein Millionär
geworden mit seinem erfolgreichen
Showbusiness in Moskau mit seinem
russischsprachigen komischen Shows wo er
auch ab und zu Witze über die Ukraine
macht und das passten den Russen zu wenn
jetzt Lenski die Verkörperung des
ukrainischen Kampfgeist des es und er
ist es und wenn er jetzt so die Ukraine
zu diesem Kampf gegen den Aggressoren
Russland führt dann ist es aus der Sicht
der moskowiten ist es etwas was nicht zu
verzeihen ist dann bist unser Typ
gewesen was ist mit dir passiert würde
ich gerne mal ihre Einschätzung weil sie
ja in Moskau sind wie wird da selenski
gesehen und war er vorher so gef erklärt
und ist ja jetzt halt eben der Feind
Nummer eins
man hat ihn gesehen und man sieht ihn
heute weiterhin man hat ihn in diesem
Shows gesehen und heute wird er dann
halt eben gerne in den Nachrichten und
bei jeder Gelegenheit einfach wird immer
wieder irgendeine Szene und dann
möglichst unvorteilhaft aus der
Vergangenheit eingeblendet das heißt
also er wird als Witzfigur letztendlich
degradiert und auf diese Weise versucht
man ihn dann darzustellen als einen der
eigentlich als Gegner gar nicht ernst zu
nehmen ist weil der wäre ja gar nicht da
wenn nicht die große Nase und wenn nicht
die Amerikaner hinter ihm stimmten also
letztendlich im Grunde genommen nur so
als so ein Stellvertreter der für die
Amerikaner steht gegen die man da
eigentlich Kämpfe und an am Ende kommt
natürlich in dieser Haltung und der da
liegt wie ich glaube dann noch eine alte
Überheblichkeit eine russische und auch
durchaus koloniale Überheblichkeit
gegenüber den Ukrainern insgesamt weil
man eben die Ukraine immer als im Grunde
genommen regional
in Russland wird immer wieder gesagt das
Land am Rande und das ist insoweit
greift dieses Bild von silenski über in
ein altes russische Stereotyp von der
Ukraine mit dem Putin in diesem Krieg
von Anfang an gearbeitet hat er soll zu
Wessel was ist jetzt die Stärke von
selensky da wo war dieser also war es
wirklich an diesem Tag als der Krieg als
die Russen Angriffen dass er dann die
tatsächliche Wandlung zu diesem
Staatspräsidenten gemacht hat oder wie
haben Sie ihn beobachtet
also er hat zwei Wandlungen durchgemacht
würde ich sagen das eine ist als er
Präsident geworden ist ich meine es in
dieses Präsidentenamt gekommen man kann
sagen als ein Populist der Mitte er hat
sich vieler populistischer Methoden
bedient aber er hat niemanden
ausgegrenzt er ist aus der Mitte
gekommen er hat ein integratives Projekt
verfolgt was jetzt keine nationalen
Minderheiten
ausklammerte und die zweite Verwandlung
nachdem seine Präsidentschaft durchaus
nicht nur erfolgreich verlaufen ist ist
dann eben der 24 Februar gewesen wo er
und das hat auch was mit seiner Bühnen
erfahren zu tun wo er die richtigen
Sätze zum richtigen Zeitpunkt gesagt hat
ich suche keine Mitfahrgelegenheit
sondern ich suche Mann ich brauche
Munition nicht dieses klare Bekenntnis
zu seiner Nation was ihn auch zu einem
Symbol der Ukraine gemacht hat wo sehen
Sie seine Stärke am meisten von sich
wenn sie ihn so beobachtet haben also
was die ich glaube der der größte wenn
man es jetzt mal unter sozusagen
politischen also was politische Symbolik
angeht sein größter Kuh war dass er da
geblieben ist also selbst die Leute die
ihn nicht gewählt haben die ihm vieles
vorgeworfen haben vor dem 24 februar
haben gesagt hut ab dass er geblieben
ist das war ganz wichtig dass das ist
auf jeden Fall das entscheidende und er
hat natürlich eine eine die die die
Menschen in seiner Umgebung sind
meistens Männer kommen zu einem sehr
sehr großen Teil aus den Medien die am
Fernseher Erfahrung die im Kino
Erfahrungen das sind ehemalige producer
die wissen natürlich ganz genau das ist
wichtig das ist wichtig Stadien wird
tagelang abgetaucht nachdem die
deutschen überfallen hatten die so wird
Union und das ähm das ist natürlich in
so einer Situation entsetzlich und
selenski war da und hat vom ersten Tag
angesagt wir sind da und wir verteidigen
wir kämpfen er hat dann so ein bisschen
so eine
Churchill auf die eine oder andere Weise
dann auch in seine Reden da ganz am
Anfang einfließen lassen also fast
wörtlich muss man sagen sagen und das
ist natürlich schon sehr sehr wichtig
gewesen ich würde eine Sache glaube ich
muss man so ein bisschen im Kopf
behalten wenn wir über silencek reden
und das ist sozusagen das
unterschiedliche Vorwissen die Ukraine
und auch die Russen aber eben vor allen
Dingen die Ukraine beobachten sie Lenski
seit Jahren vor dem 24
sie kennen ihn aus dem Kino aus dem
Fernsehen aus vielen Shows die deutschen
Hand aufs Herz haben ihn ich würde mal
sagen in breiter Öffentlichkeit am 24
Februar letzten Jahres kennengelernt das
heißt bei seiner Wahl war es ja auch so
ein bisschen Schauspieler der würde ich
sagen das war so ja jetzt nicht nur mit
Wohlwollen bedanken
Schauspieler wie aber sozusagen für die
Ukraine ist sozusagen diese neue
Wahrnehmung also viele Ukraine mit denen
ich gesprochen habe haben gesagt ich
habe nicht für ihn gestimmt ich fand ihn
immer lächerlich und er hat viele Fehler
gemacht aber jetzt ist er unser
Präsident aber die mussten Dinge hinter
sich lassen in Deutschland war das nicht
so da war er mehr oder weniger ein
unbeschriebenes Blatt
immer ein Problem ich erinnere nur an
Ronald Reagan den wir auch unglaublich
unterschätzt aber am Ende hatte die
Mittelstreckenraketen mit Gorbatschow
abgeschafft in Europa und hat den Kalten
Krieg beendet also
soweit bei Schauspielern sollte man
immer zweimal hingucken was in den
steckt und silenski ist ein guter
beweist ja und er nutzt sie seine
schauspielerischen Fähigkeiten ihr
anscheinend also die gibt's Punkte wo
sie sagen da waren sie überrascht und
die hat haben ihnen vor vorher nicht so
gut gefallen ja also das war so ich war
also wie nicht weniger vor dem
Präsidentschaftswahl da müssen wir ja
2019 deutlich skeptische gegenüber auch
weil ich äh wie es schon gesagt worden
war diese Lenski in seinen medialen
auftreten beobachtete und die waren
nicht immer gelungen
und da wollte man fragen okay gut was
ist sein politisches Programm der kam
ganz bewusste den Wahlen ohne
politisches Programm der kam mit seiner
Versprechen ich mache kein Versprechen
damit ich diese dann später nicht bereue
[Musik]
ein bisschen das war ein bisschen so
unsicheres und da dachte man ob es
richtig die gute Wahl ist dann kam es
natürlich die anderen beiden anderen
Ukraine Rennen mit welchen Sprache da
gab es die anderen Fragen zu selenski
der sprach z.B fast keine Ukraine ist
damals im Jahr 2019 das sah
seltsam aus
und der Verstand doch von sichtlich
nicht ganz
diese Rivalität zwischen der Ukraine und
Moskau ist auch verständlich war weil er
viele Jahre in Moskau arbeitet in dieser
Folge Geschichte hat hatte dies das
desto mehr ist seine Transformation Wert
und damals sagte ich meinen Freunden
schaut mal die Ukraine ist dafür bekannt
dass die Ukraine die Leute welche zu
Macht kommen entweder zu den
kämpferischen Anführern macht oder wie
eine korrig müssen sie das Land
verlassen und mit selensky ist das
genauso passiert der ist zu einem Bild
des Kampfgeistes der Ukrainerinnen
geworden und ich glaube auch seine
Vergangenheit macht ihm diese diesen
guten Dienst weil er spielt jetzt ganz
erfolgreich diese Rolle und genießt die
und macht die ganze natürlich und alle
verzeihen ihm dann was vorher nicht so
gut oder ist es so ein Punkt da muss man
jetzt einfach nicht mehr drüber reden
ist das auch nach diesen schrecklichen
nach diesem schrecklichen Krieg dass man
sagt das ist jetzt endlich spielt es
auch keine Rolle mehr was vorher ich
würde in die Richtung argumentieren vor
allen Dingen muss man sehen was macht
jemanden wie selensky eigentlich möglich
also ich finde es gibt eine Art silenski
Effekt könnte man das nennen
er ist ein Politiker der auf bestimmten
kulturellen Voraussetzungen beruht also
in der Ukraine gibt es in gewisser
Hinsicht kann man sagen 40 Millionen
silenskys wenn man silensky als jemanden
auffasst der für eine multikulturelle
Ukraine steht ich meine die Tatsache
dass er Jude ist ist
bemerkenswert dass jemand in dieses
Präsidentenamt gewählt werden kann aber
dazu muss man noch wissen dass eben auch
Baptisten das auch griechisch Katholiken
und auch russisch orthodoxe in höchste
Staatsämter gewählt werden können und
zwar nicht nur nach diesem deutschen
Korporatismus des Ämter nach Konfession
verteilt werden sondern religions spielt
einfach nicht ihre Rolle und das ist
eine Art von
multikultureller Politik die natürlich
historisch und kulturelle
Voraussetzungen in der Ukraine hat und
darüber wissen wir wirklich viel zu
wenig also wir wissen auch zu wenig über
den Politiker selenski aber noch weniger
wissen wir über die kulturellen
Voraussetzungen auf denen er aufbaut er
ist Thomas er ist im Moment der richtige
für dieses Land weil er hat ja so eine
hohe Zustimmung ist das dadurch dass er
die hohe zustimme wird das denn in
Russland registriert also ist es sowas
wo also wie reagiert Putin darauf
dass das wird natürlich wahrgenommen
aber es wird nicht in irgendeiner Form
weiter verbreitet ist auf seine
Zustimmungsraten da liegt man in
Russland wieder Wert noch würde man sie
in irgendeiner Form im Staatsfernsehen
wiedergeben was für für Sie im
Staatsfernsehen und für viele Russen ist
selensky letztendlich durch einen Zufall
in dieses Amt gespült und immer noch so
ein bisschen der von früher aber lassen
Sie mich noch eins sagen zu selensky als
Person auch vorher und wirklich nachher
nach dem Krieger ich war in Kiew
wochenlang bevor der Krieg ausbrach und
damals war silenski in schweren Wasser
es war ein Prozess angestrengt gegen
seinen Amtsvorgänger poschenko täglich
Demonstrationen von poroschenko
Anhängern
drumherum um das Land die Russen man
hatte den Eindruck der hatte überhaupt
keinen rechten Kompass wo die Reise
jetzt eigentlich hingehen sollte
davon war einiges glaube ich Täuschung
die hatten sich schon in der Ukraine
ganz gut vorbereitet in bestimmten
Bereichen und trotzdem war er politisch
furchtbar abgelenkt ähm wir wissen nicht
wie wenn es zu einem Waffenstillstand
kommt und dann zu irgendeinem unruhigen
Frieden wie sie Lenski dann agieren
würde und wie er halt in einer dann
relativ
normalen Situation reagieren würde das
Wort von oder der Ver mit Churchill
wurde eben schon mal von Sonja ziegri
angesprochen wir wissen alle dass
Churchill
1945 gleich nach dem Krieg von Clement
Adly abgelöst wurde und die Engländer
offenbar dachten naja gut
guten Job gemacht aber im Frieden gehen
wir lieber mit einem anderen weiter
da wissen wir wirklich noch nicht ganz
ob sie Lenski dann derjenige ist die die
der die Ukraine auch nach dem Kriege
weiterführen kann ohne dass ich jetzt
sagen könnte wer würde ihm dann
Nachfolge der steht da schon in den
Startlöchern aber
jetzt da ist kann es dir auch sein der
ja dann auch in dem Frieden sein Land
führt ja das ist das wäre dann eine sehr
schwierige Aufgabe für ihn ich glaube
ein Präsident zu werden zu bleiben in
der Ukraine nach dem gewordenen Krieg
und die Unterstützung zu behalten von
dem Volk ist eine kompliziertere Aufgabe
vergleichbar mit dem Russland zu
besiegen
die Ukraine sind dafür bekannt sehr
kritisch gegenüber ihrer Regierungen
auszusprechen in den 30 Jahren der
Unabhängigkeit der Ukraine über 30
Jahren es gab nur einen mal als der
Präsident die Wiederwahlen gewonnen hat
und nur weil der Gegenkandidat kurz von
Wahlen starb wir sein Haupt opponent
wäre dann Unfall
normalerweise wählen die Ukrainerinnen
ihre Präsidenten ab oder vertreiben sie
aus dem Lande und hier also das ist eine
gewaltige Aufgabe stellen Sie sich vor
sie ist jetzt wie alt 43 44
der gewinnt jetzt den Krieg der besiegt
Russland was niemand glaubte möglich
wäre
was ist die Aufgabe welche für diesen
Mann noch passend ist wohin muss er wenn
er 80 wäre dann hätte er gesagt ich
ziehe mich zurück in das private Leben
aber was macht er jetzt und wen er die
Ukraine dann nach dem Krieg wieder
bebauen wird dann wird es Fragen kommen
was mit dem Geld warum in diesem und
diesem Region unter welchen Bedingungen
dieser Frieden dann genau gemacht
kritisiert werden und es werden genug um
glückliche Leute geben welche ihm das
vorwerfen werden das wird schwierig für
ihn sein also ein Präsident auf Zeit
ganz klar also ich glaube die große
Stärke und das was die Ukraine ja selber
von sich auch als sozusagen das
Distinktionsmerkmal gegenüber den
Russinnen und Russen immer ins Feld
führen ist ja genau diese
ich will nicht einer Schienen weil das
ist es nicht aber dieser dieser
konfrontationsbereitschaft was die
politische Klasse angeht also
wenn man dass man einfach da ist niemand
der sich hinsetzt und insofern ist das
eigentlich auch eine relativ untypische
Situation gerade dieses da ist jetzt der
der selensky und den finden wir gut und
das zweite was ich in paarmal schon
gehört habe als ich in der Ukraine war
auch von Kollegen von Journalisten
die drucken jetzt nicht alles was sie
wissen sie schonen und jetzt ist nicht
die Zeit selensky kontrolliert die
Medien anfangs noch mehr aber immer noch
anfangs haben die ukrainischen
Journalisten das auch noch mal mehr
mitgemacht jetzt haben sie das zum Teil
gar nicht mehr sehen das auch nicht mehr
so richtig ein aber wie wirklich die
Ukraine als Land in ihrer Wirtschaft in
ihren politischen Entscheidungen durch
diesen Krieg gekommen ist
da haben ja selbst die Ukraine noch
nicht mal also höchstens punktuell eine
Vorstellung von und insofern ist dieses
sozusagen wir wissen nicht wie das alles
zu Ende geht und wir wissen noch nicht
mal ob sie Lenski bis zum Ende bleibt
wir wissen einfach sehr wenig das kann
ich nur zustimmen äh also wir wissen und
das beobachte ich sehr intensiv auch in
den sozialen Medien in der Ukraine das
was die Medien jetzt öffentlich den
selenski und seinem Team vorwerfen ist
deutlich zurückhaltende als was
dieselben Journalisten privat sagen und
das ist ein Teil des Deals wir haben
jetzt den Fall in Russland und Putin und
sie wollen als eine Nation aus diesem
Fight rausgehen weil das Ziel Russlands
ist die Ukraine zu tilgen und dann sind
die politischen Konflikte nicht so
bedeutend aber das bedeutet bei weitem
nicht dass dem silensky gewisse Fragen
nicht danach gestellt werden und desto
mehr werden Sie gestellt in der
lebendigen Demokratie wenn der Druck des
Krieges weg ist und diese alle Fragen
dann praktisch so gesammelt sind wie
muss ich mir silence gegen vorstellen in
seiner Macht Ausübung der Schutzweste
ist das so ein harter Hund oder der
nette Kumpel wie er manchmal wirkt also
gibt's wie hat er und und von wem lässt
er sich da eigentlich beraten von wo
holt er sich da Stärke also zunächst mal
Demokratie Präsidenten sind ja dazu da
dass sie am Ende abgewählt werden nicht
also Präsidenten auf ewig gibt es nicht
höchstens in Russland und nicht mal dort
wie wir hoffen
die alles das was wir jetzt überlegt
haben hängt natürlich letztlich von dem
Waffenstillstand ab der dann mal
geschlossen wird und nur wenn die
territoriale Integrität der Ukraine
wieder hergestellt wird stellen sich
überhaupt die Fragen also wenn die
Ukraine tastaturium einbüßt dann ist das
auch das Ende der Präsidentschaft von
silenski höchstwahrscheinlich
aus einer historischen Perspektive würde
ich sagen vieles was wir jetzt im Krieg
beobachten also dass er
von Kritik geschont wird ist irgendwie
selbstverständlich aber es gibt einige
wenige Dinge die absolut erstaunlich
sind finde ich also im Krieg wird
normalerweise eine integralistische
nationalistische Stimmung geführt wir
erleben ist dass zum Beispiel
lgbt-rechte gestärkt werden in der
Ukraine wer Leben ist das
silenski im Krieg einen
Alltag ankündigt nämlich das muslimische
Fastenbrechen für eine religiöse
Minderheit das finde ich erstaunlich und
das wird auch aus einer historischen
Perspektive bleiben also da ist er
anders aber genau auf wen
hätte man was weiß man über seinen
seinen Stab seine Berater es gab ja auch
Menschen die ja dann entlassen hat in
den aufgehört haben für ihn zu arbeiten
also wie wie hart ist es immer er muss
ja sich total verlassen können auf die
Menschen um ihn herum ja und das mit der
von Ihnen genannten Ausnahme dass kann
er auch er hatten eigentlich hat er dann
einen super Team zusammengestellt und in
der Tat ähm ist dieses Team erkennt ihn
natürlich schon aus früheren Zeiten
häufig Leute aus dem gleichen Metier wie
er selbst aber nicht nur und eben ein
auch ein sehr kluger Wirtschaftsberater
ein politischer Berater der
die näher sozusagen auch unmittelbar
nach Kriegsausbruch Sonja zietli sagt es
vorhin diese Szene der stand er halt
eben vor seinem Präsidentenpalast in den
ersten Tagen und sagte wir sind alle da
der Präsident ist da und podojak ist da
der kam so als Erster und das ist halt
jemand der im Grunde genommen auch
häufig an seiner Stelle spricht
Forderung an den Westen gestellt hat
erklärt und so weiter das sind ganz ganz
wichtige Leute die ihr da um sich
geschadet hat und es ist halt so dass er
in den er teils unterirdischen Gängen
der ist ukrainischen Regierungsbezirk
ist halt eben haben die dann auch
jeweils ihre Büros wo sie sich dann
ständig austauschen und da liebt er auch
und das ist halt eben dann dass das Team
mit dem er glaube ich auch wenn es dann
zu einem Friedensschluss käme zunächst
mal die neue Zeit ginge aber die große
Frage ist dann halt eben am Ende wie
inwieweit ist das Team werden dann auch
im Frieden so funktionsfähig wie es
jetzt gerade ist und was weiß man über
seine Familie also in der Nähe seine
Frau unterstützt ihn
welche Rolle spielt die auch in der
Öffentlichkeit seine Frau spielte die
ganze Zeit in sehr große Rolle im Leben
von silenski und sie war praktisch
diejenige Person welche ihn zum großen
Teil zu seinem kommerziellen Erfolg noch
vor der Präsidentschaft geführt hat sie
kümmerte sich auch um die Texte für
seine Chance um die politische
Ausrichtung und so weiter und so fort es
wurde lange spekuliert ob sie nicht
seine Reden Frau Präsidentschaft schrieb
es wurde gesagt dass sie nicht ganz
glücklich war mit der Tatsache dass ihr
die Präsidentschaftswahlen gewonnen hat
weil sie zu Recht dass sich vorstellen
konnte dass das so keine nächste Staffel
vom Diener des Volkes Fernsehshow sein
wird sondern deutlich unangenehmer und
jetzt sie macht einen ganz guten Korb
als eine Vermittlerin zwischen der
Ukraine und denjenigen Organisationen
und Institutionen weltweit wo diese
kriegerische
Aussicht um selenski da nicht passend
wäre und dann macht sie sehr viel mit
mobilitäre Hilfe mit Kulturinstitutionen
und so weiter also sie hat dann sich
komplett in diese Arbeit reingeworfen
und macht von mir aus ein sehr guten Job
aber wir wissen natürlich sehr wenig
über das private Leben von ukrainischen
top-politikerinnen jetzt aus ganz
einfachen Gründe die Familie macht die
Person sondern erpressbar und dort wo
sie auftaucht macht das richtig gut
ja alles andere wäre ja auch sozusagen
bei dem Ehemann und dem Milieu war ja
auch dann sehr erstaunlich sie ist
glaube ich einmal hat sie ein vor paar
sich geleistet der hat sie eine Titel
geschrieben gemacht die in der Ukraine
gar nicht ankam weil die so glamourös
war zu glamourös für den Krieg ich
wollte aber noch eine Sache anfügen weil
sie gefragt haben wie führt er wie ist
er wenn mit ihm zusammenarbeitet und das
was wir ja auch von ihm gesehen haben
ist dass er sich auch dann sehr schnell
von Leuten trennt wenn sie nicht haltbar
sind als Korruptionsvorwürfe lauft laut
geworden sind hat er Leute in sehr
kurzer Zeit ist er losgeworden
die ihnen lange begleitet haben und wenn
man ich glaube wenn man mal kritischere
Töne über silenski hören wollte müsste
man mal den Bürgermeister von Kiew
fragen wie tali Klitschko also ein
Termin mit selensky und mit Klitschko am
selben Tag ist ein ziemliches
Hängen und Würgen weil sie sich so
eifersüchtig beäugen also er ist am Ende
am Ende ist er auch Machtpolitiker das
muss er wahrscheinlich auch sein als
wäre er nicht in dieser das muss er sein
sozusagen vor allem also sozusagen bei
allem was sonst an ein schöner Fassade
und an image da ist der Kern ist
natürlich auch in Machtpolitiker was
kann man aus der politischen
Kommunikation silence lernen
oder was können unsere Politiker
vielleicht daraus lernen naja also ich
würde sagen es beginnt
selbstverständlich mit der Art und Weise
wie er sich auf seine Zuhörer und
Zuschauer einstellt ich fand es immer
faszinierend wenn er sowohl vor dem
Bundestag wie auch vor dem Londoner
Unterhaus auftrat oder Kongress in
Washington er hatte sich immer bestens
informiert auch da übrigens wiederum
seine Berater die ihn da einfach auch
entsprechend vorbereitet hatten und er
hatte dann jeweils in der jeweiligen
politischen Kultur entsprechend immer
die gewisse Zitate Bezüge auf die
Geschichte genommen die dann eben
einfach sehr durchschlagenden Effekt
hatten also das und ich glaube diese Art
sich auf das Gegenüber einzustellen und
genau diese entsprechenden Punkte
anzusprechen die die dort tatsächlich
auch resonieren und von der Effekt haben
dass dass es sicher etwas was man lernen
kann also im Grunde genommen nicht nur
aus dir selbst heraus und deine eigenen
Situation denken sondern halt eben genau
vorbereitet
aus historischer Sicht gibt es ähnliche
Persönlichkeiten gibt es Menschen wo sie
sagen würden daran erinnert mich
selensky oder gibt es Vorbilder
vielleicht für ihn Vorbilder weiß ich
nicht aber eine Ähnlichkeit würde mir
einfallen auch wenn Sie jetzt auf den
ersten Blick vielleicht nicht
funktioniert und zwar wetzlaffael also
Havel ist viel
stärker Philosoph auch gewesen deswegen
denkt man die beiden nicht zusammen aber
erstmal kennen natürlich beide die Bühne
also haben will als Dramaturg und
Schreiber und
selenski als Schauspieler
und dazu kommt dass ihnen ähnliches
Politik Verständnis gehabt haben bzw
haben antiinstitutionelle
wechselnden Politikverständnis was sehr
stark an Vorstellungen von Freiheit
Gerechtigkeit auch Gemeinschaft davon
geleitet ist
und sie haben in einem hohen Maße
universale Werte aufgenommen und das
vermocht was was Michael Schumann gerade
angesprochen hat nämlich das Gegenüber
zu adressieren und das Gegenüber ist in
beiden Fällen Europa also nicht nur
Europa auch die Welt aber in hohem Maß
Europa
haben will wie selenski wenden sich an
die europäische Politik und erinnern die
europäischen Politikerinnen und
Politikern ihre eigenen Werte
und das ist ein hochinteressanter und
wichtiger Prozess also weil dieser
könnte sagen der Golfstrom der
europäischen Identität davon abhängt
dass er immer wieder von der Seite von
der Peripherie aus gefährdeten
Situationen aus dem dividendentum
angesprochen wird und abgerufen wird
wenn sie jetzt der lensky treffen würden
was wäre für sie die wichtigste Frage
die sie im ganz stellen würden
vorausgesetzt wird die ehrlich antworten
was glaubt er wie es weitergeht was
glaubt mir wie dieser Krieg endet
ja ich würde ihm viel Erfolg wünschen
also eine Frage zu stellen die Situation
wäre zu egoistisch persönlich ein Held
der verkörperte Ukraine und die Ukraine
ist eine Held die nennen Nation
heißt für sie ist ja auch Einheit
selbstverständlich also was wir hier
haben ist die Kampf um die Freiheit um
den Frieden und um das Leben und das was
die Ukraine jetzt zahlen mit ihrem
Flugzeug ist Ihre Investition in unserer
Sicherheit und das ist immer noch bei
uns zu wenig wahrgenommen wir sprechen
sehr viel darüber ob sie lenskis
auftreter emotional hilfreich sind das
ist eine eigentlich ein ganz schlechtes
Zeichen da wir sollten Ukraine aus
Kalkül auch unterstützen nicht nur aus
Emotionen aber natürlich ist eine
Heldinnen Nation ganz kurz noch gibt
eine Frage wie Sie einstellen können ja
ich würde ihn fragen wie er sich die
Ukraine als Nationen im Frieden
vorstellt und wie diese Nationen dann
halt ihr Verhältnis zu Russland
definiert ich würde ihn nicht über die
Zukunft fragen bin über die
Vergangenheit ich würde ihn fragen was
sind eigentlich die Figuren die Wert in
der ukrainischen Geschichte an denen er
sich orientiert das ist der Historiker
vielen Dank Herr Thomas
der Tag bis dann
[Musik]